All right, Tristan on Twitter asked,
"What is the most underrated copywriting
book that you would recommend?" The most
underrated one that I would recommend is
this one. Very good copy by my friend ah
Eddie Schlainer. Okay, Eddie Schlainer
wrote this book. And the reason it's one
of the most underrated is it's like 500
pages, but it is so easy to read. Every
chapter is like maybe a thousand words.
takes you a couple minutes to read each
chapter and it just the pacing is
perfect, the storytelling is perfect. It
is not one of those like hard teaching
copywriting books. It's just jam-packed
filled with great stories and then you
get a little tiny lesson at the end of
each story THAT YOU'RE LIKE, "OH MAN,
THAT IS so good." So, if you're looking
for something easy, casual, and fun to
read while you are learning copy, highly
recommend. Very good copy. Excellent
book.